Nathan starts off this hour in Lexington
Kentucky a Nathan welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave thanks for taking
my call I have a question I'm on baby
steps too right now and we should have
our desks get off by the end of February
I'm wondering if I should take the home
equity line of credit that I took get
out of my home and grow that as a
babysit too also if it is less than half
your annual income okay it's about
eighty eighty thousand dollars and your
household income is what five - yeah put
that at baby step six
and what's the balance on your first
mortgage first mortgage is right at 84
and the house yeah what's the property
worth one ninety so you you haven't
borrowed up to your eyeballs then no not
yet
no I mean youyou owe one ninety aunt
ninety-four on it and it's worth one
ninety yeah at the 200 mark okay and
what is the interest rate on your first
mortgage at some point in the future you
may want to look at refinancing and
rolling these two together you probably
can't do that right now you come because
you're upside down in the house and I
don't think you're going to get a
traditional mortgage at a four point one
two five rate which you probably could
get a mortgage at that rate on a 15-year
fixed but I'm not sure you can with
enough to pay off your second mortgage
and your first mortgage and roll them
and roll them together so for now I
would just leave that sitting back there
baby step six and in the future when
you've got some equity if interest rates
are still advantageous then I would look
at going ahead and refinancing and
putting them together because you're
going to pay it's gonna take you a while
to pay this thing off and the terms and
usually the interest rates on second
mortgages usually suck and so you are
going to want to get rid of it but it's
it's back there baby step six
clean up your little debts the other
stuff your student loans whatever else
you've got
build your emergency fund start
investing and then it's begin to work
down to your baby step 6